we were in in Europe for a honeymoon at
one of the parts of the trip was to go
from Switzerland to Italy and instead of
going over the Alps they said take the
train it's a flatbed car it takes three
cars bumper to bumper and then you go
through the Alps by the way the third
tunnel is 50 minutes long if you're a
honeymooner
and I said say no more this tunnel was
completely dark and I'm like trying to
get my trousers off within a short
period of time I start seeing the
features of my beautiful wife's face and
I'm thinking my eyes are getting
acclimated to this yeah you're ahead of
me aren't you the eyes aren't getting
used to Total pitch black what happened
is that we were coming to a station
within seconds Wham we're out in Broad
Daylights sunlight everything what
happened to the 50 minutes that's what I
said I can see the the two couples
Italian couples in in the car behind it
my wife says those three words to you
who every husband wants to hear get off
me